From lethal workouts to secret Beck hat-tips,
You Season 3 is packed with tons of sneaky
easter eggs, call-backs, and pop culture references.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
I'm Jan and in this video I'm revealing the
top 40 things/ 40 killer details you might
have missed in Season 3 of You.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you're not
caught up.
When Joe becomes obsessed with his neighbour
Natalie, as we see him go off to snoop on
her, he grabs his old trusty stalking cap,
which has been placed on top of an Ernest
Hemingway biography, a nod to how he dressed
up as the famous author for Beck's birthday
party in Season 1.
Why are you wearing a turtleneck?
I'm Hemingway.
And it's also a hat-tip to how the author
came up during one of the dates Joe went on
to make Love jealous in Season 2:
You know your Hemingway.
Very sexy.
And the seed for Joe's decision to get away
from Love and take Henry with him is planted
in his mind during his conversation with Natalie
who comments that "kids aren't handcuffs".
It's a neat little remark that calls back
to the literal handcuffs that Joe almost killed
Love with in the Season 2 finale, before she
blurted out she was pregnant with his child,
stopping him in his tracks.
He is the only reason I'm alive.
While Joe is creepily stalking Natalie at
the library, he's stood right next to a stand
of Scott Landon books, a wicked reference
to the Stephen King novel Lisey's Story, which
features a stalker harassing the wife of author
Scott Landon.
After Joe murders Marienne's ex-husband Ryan,
as he walks away from the crime scene, he
sarcastically comments...
Always stay through Shavasana.
...a humorously dark reference to the Yoga
position commonly known as the corpse pose
which involves lying like a dead body on your
back, which is how Ryan ends up right outside
a yoga studio.
When Joe and Marienne discover they shared
a similar childhood as they were both abandoned
by their parents, a connection between the
pair begins to form.
The beginning of their illicit relationship
is also signalled by the fact they're standing
next a book titled "Truly Madly Guilty".
As Joe tries to keep his marriage with Love
on an even enough keel that she doesn't find
out about Marienne and kill her, he gets his
wife a present of an expensive casserole dish
she's been looking for and it's also filled
with Donut Pal.
This is a throw-back to Season 2 when Joe
missed out on a trip for that same fresh strawberry
and cream-filled dessert with Love.
The things that this donut shop does with
fresh strawberries should be considered a
sex crime.
And they were also the same doughnuts Milo
got for Love when she and Joe broke up.
When Love's mum Dottie drunkenly rolls up
for some Mexican food, the place she goes
to is called "Tacos de la Madre", which translates
literally from Spanish as "Mother's Tacos".
The choice of that particular food for her
and Henry certainly isn't a coincidence either,
because Dottie believes that Love's baby is
Forty reincarnated, and in both the TV show
and the original books Forty is addicted to
Taco Bell.
And, of course, Dottie, like Forty, was on
a bender that moment in the show herself.
He's the reincarnation of my son, Forty, and
he loves a good taco.
Don't you, baby?
The name of the fictional town where Love
and Joe live, Madre Linda, also reflects Season
3's emphasis on motherhood.
In Spanish, it means "lovely or beautiful
or wonderful mother", a reference to how after
moving there, Love initially finds herself
struggling to fit in with seemingly perfect
mothers like Sherry, a successful momfluencer.
Joe describes Madre Linda as the safest neighbourhood
in California at the beginning;
but ironically by the end, it's become notorious
for multiple gruesome murders and kidnappings
all supposedly committed by the town's new,
less-than-perfect mother, Love.
A new character in Season 3 is Theo, who has
a touch of Joe about him with his feminist
pretences and somewhat obsessive romantic
pining and pushy gestures towards Love.
Similar to Joe, Theo imitates iconic romantic
movie moments such as the scene from the 80s
movie "Say Anything" where John Cusack holds
up a boombox to prove his love.
According to all the rom-coms of your generation,
this is what the guys do to get the girl.
What Theo didn't realise though is that Love
isn't that kind of girl.
I hate rom-coms.
Take away my ovaries.
In the penultimate episode, after Theo figures
out Joe was driving Natalie's car the day
she disappeared, he goes on to discover that
the Conrads are currently locked up in the
basement of Love's bakery.
It's at this point we get to see the "Expand
Your Mind" T-shirt he's been wearing, a nod
perhaps to what a mind-blowing experience
all these discoveries have been for Theo.
When Sherry and Cary eventually find the key
that Love hid in the cage, it turns out it
was hidden inside a tub of vanilla powder,
an ironic little detail given what Sherry
called Love and Joe just before she started
looking.
Those two-faced, vanilla pieces of..
Notice also that the brand name on the tub
is French, Le Meilleur, which means 'The Best',
fitting given Love's perfectionism when it
comes to cooking.
This is the best bakery in town?
Shoddy lamination.
Definitely didn't use French butter.
Both Joe and Beck mocked the affectionate
term "babe" in the first season.
You said "babe" was a default for unimaginative
lovers.
And Love also hated the term when Milo used
it with her in the second season
If you call me "babe" again, I'm gonna stick
you in the oven.
So, it's more than coincidence that when Sherry
and Cary arrive for the swinging session with
Joe and Love, they start using the term with
each other..
Babe, I'm all over it.
..making it a little signal on top of the
many others of how the Conrads are really
worlds apart from the Quinn-Goldbergs.
God, these people are so much more f!£$%^&
up than I thought.
You's writers have a bit of fun with the dramatic
trope of Chekhov's Gun when Joe discovers
Cary brought a gun to the swinging session.
This is a Chekhov situation now, isn't it?
If I touch it, I all but guarantee it gets
fired.
The trope is fulfilled when Love gives it
to the Conrads who end up using it twice,
[and] leaving Joe regretting not having it
himself when he's getting beaten up by Ryan.
New trope: wishing you had Chekhov's gun to
fire.
The use of the trope in Season 3 also calls
back to the second season when Forty drunkenly
explained his feature film idea at Henderson's
party.
It's Chekhov's knife.
And as soon as we see it, you know throats
are gonna get cut.
Forty was right because when we saw Love expertly
using a knife to butcher a piece of meat early
in the second season, it was a big clue to
the twist that she'd be revealed as a knife-slashing
serial killer, similar to Joe.
Joe and Love's distrust of each other comes
to a head in their last meal together when
Love cooks him a roast chicken, a call-back
to when they first met and she took Joe on
a culinary tour of LA in search of his favourite
food which ended up being the roast chicken
she cooked for him that night.
Perfect bite?
Perfect.
The idea of Joe's "perfect bite" also came
up in Season 3 when he was feeling guilty
about Love making him delicious food while
he was thinking about Marienne.
Perfect bite.
Ready?
I don't think it's a coincidence that in the
library scene where Joe thinks Marienne is
starting to flirt with him, she's also putting
away a book with the title "Vessel", a signal
that she's about to become yet another vessel
for Joe to project his fantasies on to,
his latest "You", the next in his parade of
replaceable, interchangeable women from Candace
to Beck, Love, and Natalie, who he can obsess
over and fill with his idealized view of what
a perfect woman should be, then toss aside
when they don't meet his manufactured version
of them.
Joe's warped opinion of himself as a good
man, a hero even, comes up when he compares
himself to the fictional character Atticus
Finch from the Pulitzer-prize-winning book
To Kill A Mockingbird.
You're a steady, stalwart Atticus Finch.
This idea is reinforced later on when Love's
mother Dottie says Joe looks "like a young
Gregory Peck", the actor who played Finch
in the 1962 adaptation of the novel.
Marienne, however, makes a much less flattering
comparison when she makes fun of Joe's look
as he arrives at work after a photo-shoot
with Sherry.
Whole vibe's very Patrick-Bateman-meets-Venetian-gondolier.
Marienne is on the money, of course, in comparing
Joe to the fictional serial killer and unreliable
narrator from American Psycho and later on
in the finale she reveals she did have her
suspicions about him.
When Love is thinking about having a second
baby with Joe - a daughter she hopes - she
seems to settle on the name "Julia" which
is interesting as Marienne's daughter is called
"Juliette" which means "little Julia".
Of course, Joe's name begins with a "J" too,
and in a flashback we also discovered that
Joe's mother had a new son called Jacob after
she gave Joe up.
Perhaps like Joe's mother then, Love is subconsciously
trying to replace Juliette, the daughter of
Joe's new obsession, with her own little girl.
A shout-out to Alaïa who noticed that when
Joe takes on the pseudonym Nick at the very
end, it's likely a reference to Nick Carraway
from The Great Gatsby.
Similar to Joe, Nick is the narrator and a
character in F. Scott Fitzgerald's famous
novel, and there have been many other Great
Gatsby references through the series.
For instance, Joe reads from the novel to
Henry in the opening episode.
In Season 1, Joe and Beck refer to themselves
as Fitzgerald and his wife Zelda, and then
there's Forty's habit of calling Joe "old
sport" like Gatsby does.
Joe taking on the name Nick might additionally
be a subconscious reference to Dr Nicky who
he framed for Beck's murder and who I think
could be coming back for Season 4 which I
talk a lot more about in my Season 4 theories
video.
As Matthew waits for Theo, he reads about
the events in what the media's dubbed the
Quinn-Goldberg "butcher house".
An article in real-life online women's magazine
The Cut reveals that Love's reported murder-suicide
has inspired memes, art and even a K-Pop viral
hit titled "Pie4Me/Die4Me",
a nod to part of Joe's body being baked in
a pie, akin to the infamous human meat pies
made by Mrs Lovett in the tale of the serial-killing
barber Sweeney Todd.
Apparently Love's original name for her bakery
was "LoveMuffin", both a euphemism and a throw-back
to how she used to leave those sweet treats
in Joe's locker at Anavrin.
Muffins?
Yeah, I, uh...
seem to remember owing you one.
The article explains that Love wasn't able
to clear the rights to the name, which could
be a real-world in-joke as it is actually
the name of a singles website in real life.
And curiously, it's also the name of the antagonist
group in Disney's animated Phineas and Ferb.
Just use the safe word:
Hakuna matata.
Disney should sue these people.
The article's accompanying photo is from Love
and Joe's wedding and its depiction of a blood-covered
cake with a bride murderously bashing the
groom from behind is a humorous call-back
to Kiki's cupcake order at the top of the
episode:
Kiki: Hey, can you make two dozen bloody-looking
ones by tonight?
I'm having my true-crime book club over to
dish.
Both Love and Joe's use of the poison wolfsbane
on each other is a twisted reference to the
special love language they created between
themselves in Season 2.
I wolf you.
I wolf you too.
And thanks to 'Valar Morghulis' for pointing
out that Wolf is also even the brand of their
oven, which Joe uses to burn Love and their
home to the ground.
And for a full breakdown of more details you
might have missed in the Season 3 finale,
tap here to watch my Ending Explained video
or follow the link in the video description.
Just before the credits roll in the first
episode, a screen appears in honour of actor
Mark Blum, who played Mr Mooney, Joe's surrogate
father and bookstore owner in New York.
Blum sadly died in March 2020 from complications
arising from Covid-19.
So, what other details did you notice in Season
3?
And what were your favourite moments?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this video, then a like and
a share are hugely appreciated.
You can tap left for my full You playlist
including the Season 3 ending explained or
tap right for my Season 4 theories including
whether Love could still be alive.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!